こーんにちマルフォイ
みーんなの笑顔を頂きマルフォーイ
こんにちはじめしゃちょーです
みーんなはー空に憧れたことはあるだろうか
そう、キョロちゃんも空を飛びたいと思ってた時期があった
世の中にいる様々の生き物は
誰しもが飛ぼうと思ったことがあると僕は思いたいと、思っているところである
シーユーネクストタイム
落ち着こう一回
落ち着こう
ごめんなみんな…土日東京だからさ、これ今日動画５本目なんだよ
お～お　ばーふぉい（くしゃみをする音）
はーはーはー
楽しい！
ごめんね一日動画５本も、とるとちょっと、頭がおかしくなっちゃうんですけども
みんな！　俺のテンションについてきてくれ
今日紹介する商品は、こちら！
コン（机にぶつける音）
くるん、ポン！
読めない（声が上がる）
ジッ、ジッピなに、ジッピピッツて、言うのこれ？
実費？ジュッピーペッツねこれ
ジュッピーペッツっていう、鳥でございます
なんかすごいね、昔やったパタパタバードみたいだね
空を飛ぶ系です
やっぱ、空を飛ぶ系のおもちゃって、面白いんですよ結局
これ凄いのは、なんかもう、まるで本物の鳥みたいに飛ぶよって書いてあります
さえずりが、聞こえたら捕まえろよみたいな、（聞き取り不能）が、鳥をとっ捕まえようとしてますね
すごいのは、電池がいらないんだ、USB充電でできる、これはありがたいっすね
本物の鳥っぽく飛ぶって言われたら、それはこっちもこっちで気になってくるなるので
早速開けてみるよ♪
開封音
大丈夫かな…
遊び方はとりあえずあれだ！USB
とりあえず充電してきます
いや、実際に普通に楽しみだよ
だって、空飛ぶんでしょう
さすがに空飛ぶ…ので、テンションの上がらない人間は、いないと思っている
まずは、電源を入れてください　　はいあっ
ファイナルファンタジーの選ぶ時の音だ
電源を入れたら本体に置き
木にとめてください
はい、セットゥ
頭を二回押すと鳴いたりさえずりたり歌ったりします
ピョッピヨ
あっ
ピヨッピピピピピピピ
うあっ
ピヨ、ピーピピピピピイ
鳴いてる鳴いてる鳴いてる！
ピヨ、ピピピピ
おー
ぽいぽいぽい
よだれが出た、ぽいぞー、あと
頭を三回連続でたたくと、８回鳴き、飛び立つらしいです
マジ！、スゴちょちょちょ
ピヨピヨピヨ、ピヨ×８
うあー！
モーター音
イヤー！
ピヨピヨピヨ、ピヨ×８モーター音
おっきたきたきた
おっおーー
ピヨピヨピヨ
分からん、分からん
何今の
モーター音
抹茶ー
グサッ
モーター音
はいって、言うわけで
実は、３匹おります
最後にね、この３匹仲良く飛ばして、終わろうと思います
行きます！、３・２・１
ピヨピヨピヨ　ピヨ×８
グサッ　あーーー！
ピアノの音
止めろーー！
エンディング
３．２．１　バタッ　バタ